after months of qualifiers that qualify
you for qualifiers that qualify for one
big qualifier
the dust is settled and we finally know
who's going to be representing north
america
and europe in reykjavik iceland at
valerian esports first
ever lan masters 2. let me walk you
through
who that is who that isn't and how we
got here
and set the stage for what is maybe the
single esport event
i am most excited for in my entire life
[Music]
all right guys if you like valerian if
you are stoked to see some competitive
breeze play
if you can't wait for iceland i need you
to do something for me i need you to
subscribe to the channel
scroll down like the video and let us
know that you want more valorent content
just like this in the future
alright so let's start with this weekend
where valard's season two finals took
place for north america europe japan
korea
and the sca region we locked in seven of
the ten teams
that will be competing in the game's
first ever land
on may 24th that's just like
three weeks from now let's start in
north america where
the closest thing to consistency you can
even expect
in the early days of an esport sentinels
were able to plow their way through the
upper bracket and get their spotted
isolate hold my rope
one rafter he's swinging swung out
raffle more backside
spawn spawn i tagged him hit him
around the corner and zeta needs to hang
on a 1v1 zombs full hp
[Music]
i think after this weekend it's safe to
call it at least for now
sends and tens have cemented themselves
as the best team in north america and
that's really saying something because
if you've watched as much any valor and
as i have
at times it felt like the best team
fluctuated like
every four days so congrats to sentinels
but i think it's safe to say that
them qualifying wasn't the most
surprising thing to come out of north
america this weekend
it's who else qualified and who didn't
qualify to tell that story
let's go back in time a little bit to
last wednesday
on the eve of the na finals heading into
the weekend
the favorites to represent na in
addition to sentinels
i would say were 100 thieves and envy
simply due to their consistency during
the masters one season
and the fact that these rosters are
filled with og counter-strike players
they know how to play when the
pressure's on now as many of you
probably already know
when the dust settled and it came time
for the winners and losers bracket
finals on saturday
neither of those teams were in the
running to get their spot on land
instead it came down to sentinels cloud
nine
and version one in the upper finals
sentinels had to defeat cloud nine which
was particularly poetic because
tens had to defeat the team that well
sort of
owns him after cloud9 has been a
non-factor for like
weeks but tens and company holding on
but the response from cloud9 has been
swift as well but since
it's gonna go all the way for the ace
you have to be kidding me
that sent c9 down to the lower bracket
where they had to compete for the second
and final slot in iceland against an
upstart team
called version one v1 have been kind of
popping off a little bit in recent weeks
and they're spearheaded by ex-chaos
esports counter-strike player
and their igl vanity along with zelsis
who
honestly popped off on phoenix and rey's
like all weekend and in the end it was
actually
version one who came out on top
defeating leaf and company
on cloud9 which if i'm being honest
warms my heart
it's been less than six months since
chaos esports counter-strike
was forced to break up and vanity told
us on
this literal show he was being forced to
move to valorent
because he couldn't find an org in n.a i
mean we knew back in like
october i think we were getting released
and honestly i kind of like expected it
like
throughout the year because we were
gonna delayed payments and stuff we
never had sponsors
so it was kind of just like uh investor
money and stuff and that's never gonna
last
like super long right so i mean kind of
sucks but it is what it is it wasn't
super unexpected
given like the circumstances around the
year like there was just a bunch of like
foreshadowing
regarding it all and i mean it sucks but
it's not the end of the world
sometimes the good guys do win
[Music]
okay now let's talk about europe because
for my money i was actually more shocked
by the results there
than i was in it fnatic and team liquid
will be heading to iceland
representing the region which doesn't
sound that shocking right
this is the biggest tournament in valor
and esports so far
so obviously we have two legacy esports
orgs
representing europe but the reality is
in europe
the big time esports orgs have not had
that much success in valor
at least until this weekend fnatic and
liquid didn't even make it as far as the
masters won
tournament in europe let alone compete
for the title with that said
i am very impressed at team liquid's win
this past weekend they look like a
well-oiled machine throughout the event
and in traditional european style they
gave us some unique
looks as far as team compositions and
how they approach these maps
[Applause]
[Music]
they only played sova on two out of the
five maps in the finals and they favored
brimstone
over omen and astra on smoke their most
notable standouts were obviously scream
who was the finals mvp
and yompi whose transition from cs to
valorem is clearly going pretty well
when it comes to these after plant
scenarios it can be topped off
from yummy [ __ ] both the fin is just
going
flashy at this stage if you don't know
yampi was a standout young talent in
counter-strike
but due to a lingering vac ban from when
he was barely a teenager
he hasn't really been able to carve out
a name for himself
which led to him literally suing valve
over the back bin
to take that one step further the
consequences of that back ban have
actually
recently changed and due to some valve
sanctioned miracle
if yampi ever did return to
counter-strike he would be allowed to
play in majors again
valve has made it so that vac bans are
temporary well certain ones not all of
them
but still it's something after years of
begging and pleading the iron curtain
has been lifted with valve
finally showing some modicum of mercy
when it comes to rehabilitating cheaters
so if you're a team liquid valor and fan
you could say
that this win this past weekend was
pretty well timed
as for scream well you know we're still
talking about it's one taps
counter rather of popping down the old
pushing mid to catch them
away and scream oh my god man
headshot after headshot four kills on
the board and oxygen
it's the last round of the half they
thought they had it they dealt with
yampi and so that was
surely the round going their way that
screen comes through to ruin their day
toronto's even native and southern aces
a headshot after north america and
europe
rounding out the seven teams qualified
for masters are neutron gaming from
korea
crazy raccoons from japan and x10 gaming
representing the sca region
there are three slots remaining to round
out the 10 and those will be filled by
the end of the week by
two teams from brazil and one more team
representing the latin america region
all right so now that we've gotten all
the insane action from the weekend out
of the way
there are two big talking points from
the world of valor right now that i want
to go over
before i leave you the first is the
inhuman fragging machine himself
tens now understandably there was a lot
of joking going on on twitter
when cloud9 got their spot in the upper
bracket finals against sentinels
not only was it funny that arguably the
best player in north america
was facing off against the team that was
loaning him
to his current team for a spot at the
game's first ever lan
it brought up an interesting question if
cloud9
and sentinels both made it to iceland
what team would penns play for
up until this weekend we knew that
cloud9 was loaning tens to sentinels to
play in place of sinatra
for the remainder of this challenger
season
which theoretically ended this weekend
but over the course of the weekend
cloud9's owner jack echian actually
confirmed on reddit that there was
already an agreement
in place for tens to remain with
sentinels through iceland
which means that although we don't know
how long for
it does appear like tense's relationship
with sentinels has either been extended
or is actually longer than what was
originally reported
this dude continued his absolutely
godlike performances this past weekend
and i for one cannot wait to see if he
can prove himself on land
like he never did in counter-strike
iceland
could be tenz's tournament well it's a
marshall in its tents
so you don't count it out oh my gosh you
don't count it out
he's looking for more he gets the other
one as well the last thing i want to
talk about today is perhaps the most
important thing
going on in pro valor that wasn't these
tournaments this last weekend
and that's breeze discover
something new a natural place
full of blinding beauty now new maps
are always exciting in a new game like
this everyone likes new toys
but specifically i wanted to talk about
breeze today because i think it is a
welcome addition to the competitive
environment for the game
specifically it was supposed to be added
to the pro map pool at masters 2 in
iceland
and i was stoked to finally watch pro
players play
this brand new map but on may 4th riot
games actually announced that they were
taking
brees out of the competitive map pool
for iceland
they said that it's just not fair to ask
these teams to prepare
a brand new map in such a short amount
of time and i for one am stoked because
this map is thick like
in a way that none of the other valorent
maps are it's
huge there's a ton of angles to hold and
little intricacies to learn
but i think it presents an answer to a
problem
that a lot of the valorant maps have you
see
there's obviously been a lot of talk
even on this show
about how much lower the skill ceiling
on the rifles are
in valorent versus counter-strike and
personally
i think that's mostly fine but it
becomes a lot less fine
when most of your rifling experience is
holding left click and spraying around
corners in these tight tight angles on
these tiny maps like
split i think breeze will be a welcome
challenge for these pro teams to take
long range fights to fight for mid
control and to be a little bit more
careful with their utility
because the fact is you can't just smoke
off an entire [ __ ] site on this map
they're too big
and i think that's a good thing that
said if you don't want to take my word
for it
just ask the goat himself shroud i've
been playing it a lot man i'm being real
honest with you
a lot of people don't seem to like the
map but i think it's pretty sick
i yeah i think all the top players are
going to love it and everyone else is
going to hate it
and it's a little like aim duel
everything yeah it's a little worrisome
because i think it's the best map they
ever made
so if it gets bad feedback then they
might not ever make a map like it again
so i i i want to i think that's
i think this is the direction that they
need to go with their maps in the future
now before riot games removed breeze
from iceland
they announced that they were also
adding a map veto for pro play
when breeze does go into the rotation so
my assumption although i don't know for
sure
is that that map veto will not happen in
iceland but when they do
finally put breeze into the competitive
rotation will finally get a map veto
and that's everything seven out of ten
teams
locked in for valorent's first ever land
that is again
just three weeks away it looks like tens
will be completing with sentinels so we
got an answer to that question
and we've got breeze to look forward to
all we can ask for now is that this
whole
viper and astra purple and green cloud
meta
isn't as bad at the biggest event in the
game's history
as it is in my ranked games
dimitri pascaluda the ballarat hater
himself he's gonna play jet
because the thing about dimitri is if
you put him on jet and you give him an
op
some of his like weird like boomer
counter strike
tinglings go off you know and he like
stops complaining and starts playing and
then we got niall mccrossman
who's a writer here that's definitely
the best valor player
at the score he'll put him on killjoy
because he plays killjoy and rank
i'm gonna have to play something like
team focus cause i'm not that good but
i know i know i like the game and i play
it a lot so
play like skye sean tepper he's a
you know he can play some maybe some
brimstone we're just gonna have to
rotate
absolutely annihilating sights because
we can't you can't default when devon's
around if you try to default your
position when devin's around he'll be in
the other team's spawn dying
like before you guys are but done buying
guns